journal editorial board this morning
writing about biden's immigration damage
saying that
ending title 42 quote will be this if mr
biden wanted to undermine public
confidence in the pro-immigration cause
he could not do better this is an
invitation for migrants to keep coming
in for any reason americans can be
forgiven for concluding that mr biden's
de facto policy is to allow unchecked
immigration
without admitting it will kane fox and
friends weekend co-host joining us now
will great to see you and great to have
you here this morning how much damage
will this do lifting this title 42
policy
let's put it into context sandra because
there's a ton of numbers coming at us
and to me the number that jumps out is
the one you quoted at the beginning that
if title 42 is lifted we can expect 18
000 border crossings a day
still just a number so let's see if we
can put some color on that number over a
month's period of time that's half a
million illegal border crossings that's
the united states of america importing a
city the size of kansas city every month
or atlanta or albuquerque every single
month and then ask yourself this
if you are expanding your population by
the size of kansas city or milwaukee
every single month what's inside of that
city well we're starting with a criminal
act crossing illegally is a criminal act
but you're going to import even yet more
crime look kansas city has a murder rate
in 2021 of 244
murders atlanta 158 milwaukee county on
pace in 2022 for 300. so this is what we
are asking for and quite honestly the
numbers would be much higher because
you're starting already with an illegal
act and then ask yourself what can hide
within a city the size of milwaukee
coming in every month and then you get
to bill millusion's report then you get
to tom homan
23 terrorists that we know of
in 2021 crossing illegally this is what
we're asking for and sandra before we
move on can i just say this is where the
conversation needs to go in my mind does
this represent an invasion and i'm using
that word very specifically because
here's the real issue the body
administration will do nothing about
illegal immigration we know that
can states like texas and arizona begin
to take over the process of securing our
border they can't as long as it's an
immigration issue because of the
supremacy clause of the constitution but
if it represents an invasion and this is
where the criminal cartels come in are
they invading our borders the criminal
cartels
then you have power under article 1
section 10 for governor greg abbott or
ducey or any other southern border
governor to begin to do what the federal
government will not do and that is to
keep an invasion of a city the size of
atlanta proper not metro atlanta coming
in every month well what we can say with
certainty is that there's growing
pressure from the president's own party
to do something about this you just
heard from henry cuellar chris coons and
others
so we will see
which way the president goes as he
continues to see that
that pressure from democrats meanwhile
to the point about that policy being
lifted that was intended to address
covid concerns now you have this will
president biden's new coronavirus
response coordinator saying that
lockdowns are no longer necessary to
stop the spread of covid19 listen
we are at a point in this pandemic mike
where i think we can gather safely make
sure people are vaccinated make sure you
have testing
improve ventilation these are the
strategies we have learned over the last
two years and if we implement them do i
think it's safe for people to gather
together indoors absolutely
and a wall street journal op-ed puts it
like this officials adopt new message on
covet-19 behaviors
it's your call but that's not the case
in philadelphia the city has revived its
mask mandate as case numbers there go up
but several business and some private
citizens are now suing over that mandate
will is it possible that this science is
changing or has changed this much
no the facts haven't changed the science
has changed
has not changed the politics have
changed and yet there's some that are
unwilling to give up their addiction you
know i think illegal immigration is
obviously a story about crime i think
covet is a story about addiction we know
that it has caused record spikes in
addiction but the addiction i'm talking
about sandra comes in this form it's the
addiction of certain public officials to
the power they gained over the last two
years in philadelphia it's an addiction
to the quite honestly virtue signaling
and virtue separation of those who think
vaccination or masks makes you a better
person than people that make different
choices and it's an addiction to safety
over freedom there are some who truly
have
given in to fear over the last two years
of a virus by the way that is becoming
less lethal as we go along mutating into
a more benign form of itself so it's
we're addicted to fear we're addicted to
power and we're addicted to being better
than each other interesting uh we'll see
what direction it goes a lot of things
are changing even here in new york city
the status is changing
we're going to watch how it's handled
all over the country will kane great to
have you here thank you very much
hi everyone i'm brian kilmeade i want
you to do me a favor i want you to click
to subscribe to the fox news youtube
page this is the only way that i know
for sure that you're not going to miss
any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on fox you can get it all here on
youtube so subscribe right now